your girls open
um no i mean i feel like at the end of
the day it's just about
having similar fundamentals and wanting
the same things
after this movie i feel like we're all
gonna want a princess switched
three would you do it oh it's already
happening
i'm so happy you're here there's no way
we'd miss your coordination
and uh got you a little surprised i hope
it's okay that we're here
this movie was so much fun what was the
biggest challenge for you and playing
not two characters this time but
three you know i pride myself on being a
professional
i'm showing up to set with my lines
memorized
and i would show up to set with my lines
memorized but by the end of the day
my brain was so shampooed that i was
like
i swear i know my lines i think i'm
losing my mind
just you know doing scenes with
me myself and i it was like it was
it was a lot a lot yeah presenting
lady fiona pembroke maggie moon
oh double chin that's a delete here we
go
what was it like to wear that blonde wig
um it's so much fun
i i'm such a big fan of wigs
so when i was told there was going to be
a third
character and kind of like the ideas
that they had for her
i was like she needs she needs to be
blonde like she needs to be
so over the top and i just had the best
time
creating her because they really did
give me freedom to kind of
spice her up however i wanted to
you want us to do what we switch back
you said you needed more time with kevin
do you really think we could pull it off
again
you play regal royal so well
have you ever met any of the royals
in real life or did you study any of
them to sort of nail margaret's
mannerisms um i haven't met any of them
i would love to meet the queen don't get
me wrong um
but i i i grew up doing ballet
and i think that that has always really
helped
me kind of exude that
royal essence yeah no you carry yourself
differently and
i think that just like being in the
spotlight ever since i was
16 years old like you know you kind of
figure out a way how to carry yourself
and navigate through the world of
entertainment you bring up a good point
you have been doing this
forever and there's this conversation
between margaret
and kevin and he kind of says to her you
belong with someone of a certain stature
someone who you can relate to for you i
mean having to navigate
dating in the public eye for so long do
you feel like
in your next relationship you'll look
for someone more private or do you feel
like you need to be with someone who
understands
you know your girls open
no i mean i feel like at the end of the
day it's just about
having similar fundamentals and wanting
the same things like
i am not picky
really you should be picky i am i'm
extremely picky
but like i know what i want and i'm like
if someone comes into the picture and
can give me
all those things then great it doesn't
matter if they're in the public eye or
not if anything i would prefer them not
jumping
but we'll see we'll see have you been
dating during quarantine what's that
like how
i am literally i just finished another
movie
yesterday and you know it's
taken very seriously and and to keep
everyone safe there
are precautions and at times
it feels extravagant but it's what you
have to do
to keep everyone on the production safe
so
yeah no definitely no dating
are you talking about tick tick boom yes
i am so excited for that by the way
i mean aren't you are you singing a lot
in it
yeah what what is it like to work with
andrew garfield i mean what was it like
to film during
it's fantastic i mean like i'm such a
big fan of jonathan larson
like i did rent 11 i think years ago and
then did rent for fox
and um i just i was such a love for him
and andrew really embodied
jonathan i a couple of times would be
like hey john
and i'm like me and andrew after this
movie i feel like we're all gonna want a
princess
switched three would you do it
oh it's already happening did you
already film it
nothing has been filmed yet but you know
we gotta we gotta
keep the christmas spirit alive yeah i
mean i agree
how how could you guys pull off a third
switch you know you'll have to wait and
see
i'm very excited about it though because
i will get to play a lot
will you play four characters no god no
i'm just gonna crush that rumor now that
is not happening
no one gets their hopes up for that
three is the max
b is my limit that is all that my mental
capacity can handle
ashley tisdale announced her pregnancies
how
how excited are you to watch her become
a bomb for the first time
oh my gosh it's so exciting i'm just i'm
so excited to
get back to la to sing to her baby
in her snake i am over the moon for her
and chris
they are just gonna make such incredible
parents
i cannot believe it still
but i'm very emotional and very excited
about it
will will you be the godmother i'll be
at least a fairy godmother that's for
sure
are you helping her with names at all um
no she's already got that covered
oh she's already picked names i mean i
don't know
that's so funny also in this movie i
mean we see stacy and how badly she
wants
you know margaret and kevin to work
things out would you ever let
your friends or someone like ashley play
cupid
for you i mean 100 i'm like
my friends are my family and they care
about me
so much and i think that's what it
boiled down to
for stacy and margaret you know like she
sees
her best friend who is taking on the
throne she's about to become
queen and she knows how beautiful the
relationship that she had with kevin was
um and you know like relationships are
hard they're complicated
but in the case for margaret and kevin
stacy wants them to give it another try
so like i would totally let my friends
be like
hey you should go for this and set me up
if anything
where you're at